if you really want to see how insane
this thing is getting well Saturday
Night Live which was a comedy show on
NBC for decades it used to be a comedy
show nobody watches it now it's
completely irrelevant it's ridiculous
it's partisan it's hacking and
everything else well even they are now
going after Biden I'm going to show you
it's about a 45 second clip here it's
not funny I I just want to warn you
you're not going to laugh you're going
to get the joke you're not going to
laugh the can laughed at the whole thing
but even they are now going after Joe
Biden this week President Biden pardoned
thousands of convicted marijuana users
and it feels like maybe he celebrated
with them a little because yesterday
Biden gave a speech at a car factory and
opened with this
let me start off with two herbs
made in America
spawn with two words Jesus aged Christ
has then heard criticizing reporters at
the White House for shouting questions
at him questions like what year is it
and who's the current president
also they weren't reporters they were
doctors
all right whatever they got about 40
writers that put this thing together I
got these two schmotes no offense guys